monsieur le président du sénat mesdames
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président du conseil économique social
et environnemental
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
monsieur le président de l'association
des maires de france hier françois
baroin
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
bureau et du comité directeur
adama maire de paris chère anne hidalgo
mesdames et messieurs les présidents
d'associations d'élus locaux
mesdames et messieurs les maires et
présidents d'intercommunalités mesdames
et messieurs les élus
mesdames messieurs chers amis merci
d'abord de m'avoir permis de partager un
instant à vos côtés l'hommage rendu au
président chirac hommage affectueux et
émouvant et merci de m'accueillir en
cette deuxième journée après avoir passé
ses heures et hier en particulier aux
côtés de tous nos amis et collègues
ultramarins que je reconnais dans cette
salle et qui font face à beaucoup des
défis qui sont ceux de tout le
territoire français avec en plus bien
souvent des défis bien particulier
auquel à chaque fois nous tentons de
répondre merci madame le maire de paris
share and merci monsieur le président
cher françois baroin monsieur le
vice-président cher andré laignel pour
votre accueil vos propos vos
interpellations et merci à vous tous
mesdames et messieurs les maires d'être
là nous nous retrouvons mais en fait
je ne crois pas que nous soyons vraiment
quitté à chaque fois que je me déplace
dans l'hexagone comme en outre mer
dans les circonstances tragiques d'une
catastrophe naturelle d'un attentat
comme dans les jours plus heureux pour
inaugurer tel projet qui se lancent
telle réalisation qui a abouti c'est
votre visage à cette fois que je vois
parmi les premiers votre connaissance du
terrain qui me nourrit votre sens
précisément du terrain qui m'apprend et
puis vous l'avez rappelé il y a eu le
grand débat c'est dialogue que nous
avons noué dans toutes les régions de
france à grand-bourg trou là souillac
valence evry courcouronnes autun
gargilesse-dampierre bordeaux
gréoux-les-bains angers saint brieuc
côtes than à l'elysée dans bien d'autres
lieux
ce fut ça pendant des mois dans toutes
les régions de france et j'ai tant
appris de nos échanges tant appris je
dois dire des aspirations de nos
compatriotes de leurs craintes aussi
face aux bouleversements contemporains
qu'ils vivent dans leur quotidien et que
vous partagez avec eux tant appris de
votre sens du dialogue de l'unité de la
proximité tant appris
muse de dire de vous de ces débats que
nous avons eus ensemble que j'avais
encore il ya quelques jours à epernay
avec le maire et son conseil municipal
et je dois bien le dire si mon parcours
avant de devenir président de la
république diffère quelque peu de celui
de jacques chirac à qui nous venons de
rendre hommage et qui avait forgé sa
vision de la france dans ses fonctions
locales en corrèze et à paris ou du
président mitterrand qu'il avait forgé
le rap est là aussi durant ces décennies
à château chinon ces heures passées à
vos côtés ont agi et agissent pour moi
comme un concentré d'expérience je ne
suis certes pas maire d'une commune de
france mais je me sens chaque jour un
peu plus à votre contact maire de la
commune france c'est à dire à la fois
gardien de l'essentiel l'unité de la
nation et du quotidien concret des vies
de la dimension humaine qui à la fin
doit guider toute action publique
alors cher françois baroin cher andré
laignel vous avez évoqué quelques sujets
lourds finances locales répartition des
compétences décentralisation tous ont
une importance capitale
sur ce dernier je reviendrai dans
quelques instants sur les autres je
pourrais utiliser justement le même
propos que françois mitterrand avait eu
dans son discours de 94
si j'avais voulu répondre à ces sujets
pointe à pois j'aurais fait ministre ou
premier ministre
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je vous les
envois durant tous ces jours
mais comme vous parce que les tentes
aussi changer les exigences ne sont pas
les mêmes et vous me diriez qu'est ce
que c'est que ce président qui répond
pas un autre quotidien alors que nous
nous devons répondre au quotidien de nos
concitoyens
ça fait quand même rentrer un peu dans
le concret sur la taxe d'habitation
j'ai déjà plaidé à plusieurs reprises
d'abord permettez moi de dire la taxe
d'habitation comme les dotations
je suis ce que je vous avais dit je suis
venu à votre invitation durant la
campagne présidentielle je vous ai tenu
ce discours
exactement et j'ai demandé au
gouvernement de ne mettre en oeuvre
je crois que vous êtes attaché à la même
forme de transparence
il est bon que ce soit ainsi après sur
la taxe d'habitation 6 durant votre
campagne
beaucoup de vos électeurs vous reproche
la baisse faites le moi savoir
et qu'ils viennent se plaindre et
parfois peut-être vous aurez le droit
d'empocher les félicitations qu'il vous
livre à vous et pas au gouvernement
parce que c'est ce qui va vous arriver
et je me permettrais de dire que
contrairement à beaucoup d'autres
réformes celle ci ne s'est pas soldée
par la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation pour la remplacer par un
autre impôt local ce qui fut toujours le
cas jusqu alors non mais bien par la
suppression d'un impôt compensé par
l'état qui descend en effet du
département au bloc communal un impôt
mais qu'ils compensent par une part de
transfert d'un impôt national
et ça ça n'avait jamais existé parce que
ça veut dire que le payeur finale de
cette mesure c'est bien l'état et ses
économies c'est une réalité
quant aux compensations les ministres le
premier ministre y reviendra je vous ai
entendu j'ai déjà plaidé il ya deux ans
ici même les choses je lui ai expliqué
plusieurs fois durant le grand débat si
le système des dotations doit être rendu
plus intelligent je suis preneur de
toutes les propositions
il se trouve que le système
d'aujourd'hui il est voté par le
parlement sur la base des propositions
comité des finances locales
j'ai compris que beaucoup puissent y est
j'ai simplement le gouvernement vote une
stabilité conformément à mes engagements
sans le parlement vote sur proposition
du gouvernement conformément à mes
engagements une stabilité
c'est une bonne chose mais la stabilité
elle s'accompagne ensuite de variations
en fonction de la réalité
si on perd des habitants selon le
potentiel fiscal nous connaissons les
règles si elles peuvent être rendues
plus intelligente il faut le faire
maintenant vous avez raison le système
est un parfait il faut continuer de le
transformer de l'améliorer j'y
reviendrai dans quelques instants
mais je crois que le mot le moment que
vit notre pays que nous avons traversées
ensemble ces derniers mois le caractère
parfois tragiques de notre histoire et
vous l'avez rappelé exige aussi que je
puisse ici vous dire quelques mots
quelques convictions au fond de la
manière dont nous ensemble maires de
france et président de la république
nous pouvons rassembler les français
comment nous pouvons ensemble faire en
sorte d'être à la hauteur de ce moment
car en effet ce qui importe
et je ne considère pas pour ma part que
ce que notre pays a vécu il vient
maintenant un an pendant des mois et des
mois soient totalement derrière nous
cela vient de loin et cela durera
cela exige beaucoup de force d'âme de
volonté une volonté de transformer notre
pays d'agir mais aussi tout en agissant
d'unir et de rassembler on ne pas
laisser de côté une partie de nos
territoires de notre peuple
et pour continuer à donner du sens à
chacun c'est bien cela dont je suis venu
vous parler cet après-midi avant tout
trop de fracture c'est le principal
constat qui a émergé du grand débat
national fracture territoriale fracture
numérique sociale identitaire culturelle
aussi trop de fracture comme si la
france n'était plus une
et chaque fois qu'a républicains comme
vous l'êtes
comme je le suis entend ainsi désigné la
situation de notre pays c'est toujours
un déchirement
précisément parce que la république et
et ne saurait être qu'une parce que la
république et et ne saurait être qu'un
divisible cela ne veut pas dire qu'elle
est la même partout et vous êtes
d'ailleurs les porteurs de cette
diversité
mais cette diversité ne doit pas diviser
et justifier précisément que bloc à bloc
on finissent par penser le territoire où
la société comme séparait jamais je ne
me résoudrai à ce que la france la
nation se réduisent à un archipel est
donc notre rôle à nous à vous qui êtes
en charge de la commune donc du commun
c'est de tout mettre en oeuvre pour
résorber ses fractures c'est de faire
bloc pour unir pour rassembler les
français
par notre action unir et rassembler cela
passe d'abord et avant tout je veux ici
de rappeler on l'évoquent je crois
souvent trop peu par des rites
républicains dont pour les pratiquer
vous savez l'importance dans la vie
d'une commune
les cérémonies commémoratives en sons
qui rappellent régulièrement aux
français les liens de sang qui ont
façonné leur liberté je veux ici vous
remercier toutes et tous
pour votre implication lors de
l'organisation du centenaire de la
première guerre mondiale comme dans les
différents anniversaires et
commémorations du débarquement de
normandie ou de provence et de toutes
ces célébrations encore ces jours
derniers l'année 2020 sera de ce point
de vue particulière nous célébrerons
entre autres tout à la fois les 80 ans
de l'appel du 18 juin les 120 ans de la
naissance du général de gaulle les 150
ans de la troisième république
quelques autres anniversaires importants
vous serez une fois encore au
rendez-vous mais fait rendez vous ne
sont pas des habitudes ces rixes
précisément donne du sens dans nos
communes partout dans la république à ce
lien de sang tu as cette part d'histoire
qui nous a fait libre et j'en sait toute
l'importance dans les temps que traverse
notre république ils sont autant
d'occasions de rassembler les
générations de ne pas oublier de
comprendre de continuer d'associer
toutes et tous des ducs et en impliquant
plus profondément comme nous sommes en
train de le faire l'école et d'agir unir
et rassembler c'est aussi par notre
action collective notre ambition cela
signifie en quelque sorte recoudre cette
france trop souvent déchirés déchiré
entre la ville les banlieues les
différents quartiers les campagnes avec
je le sais un exercice du mandat de
maire parfois particulièrement difficile
dans nombre de ces endroits alors ce que
nous avons collectivement à faire c'est
un nouvel aménagement de nos territoires
de notre territoire jeudi collectivement
parce que c'est à la fois le
gouvernement mais avec lui les régions
les départements les intercommunalités
et les communes qui ont ce travail à
faire car toutes les compétences à
assembler sont à mobiliser il n'y a pas
de fatalité à ses divisions chimie était
engagé le gouvernement a pris des
mesures fortes à vos côtés qui marque là
aussi un retour de l'état le plan action
coeur de ville pour redynamiser les
centres des cités moyenne l'agenda rural
porté par la concertation sur vos
propositions
avec plus de 170 actions proposées par
la ministre pour nos villages
l'installation de france service dans
chaque canton
j'inaugure est le premier français
service vendredi à amiens le plan de
mobilisation nationale pour nos
quartiers le plan très haut débit le
développement d'infrastructures de
proximité pour qu'une demeure aucune
zone blanche en matière de transport et
de ce point de vue merci président ce
que vous avez dit sur les concertations
en la matière la loi d'orientation pour
les mobilités devrait être ainsi voté ce
soir à l'assemblée nationale la création
sur la base d'une idée soumise par la mf
d'une agence nationale de la cohésion
des territoires mettant à disposition
des collectivités de nouveaux moyens
d'ingénierie pour accompagner les
projets pour aider aux investissements
plus facile car ce qui bloque souvent
c'est le manque de moyens on le sait
bien la difficulté de porter tel ou tel
projet d'avoir les compétences les
bonnes personnes
jamais autant n'avait été fait pour que
ce beau principe républicain l'égalité
ne s'applique pas seulement aux femmes
et aux hommes mais aussi aux territoires
pour que la république porte une même
attention à notre capital qu'au village
de quelques hameaux grandes villes que
c'était moyenne nous arrivons tard je le
sais et je vous écoute est tout à
l'heure et j'entends pleinement vos
arguments
attaquer des projets de regroupements
forcés de précipitation de baisse
drastique de dotations sur tel ou tel
projet mais je voudrais ici
de là où je suis défendre le premier
ministre et son gouvernement parce que
je n'ai pas le sentiment que tout ce que
vous avez décrit depuis tout à l'heure
soit des mesures qui aient été portés
par ce gouvernement ou voter par cette
majorité et j'ai peur que comme ça peut
vous arriver souvent d'ailleurs dans
votre action
il n'a eu à subir depuis deux ans et
demi les conséquences de beaucoup de
réformes qui venait parfois de loin
alors même que son action essayé de
donner le contraire je ne vous demande
pas la patience pour concitoyens ne vous
la donne pas mes genoux demandent
collectivement le discernement qui est
de ne pas reprocher aux 1 les causes qui
viennent d'ailleurs et de savoir
reconnaître de manière un peu justes qui
est fait
[Applaudissements]
mais tout cela est une épreuve parce que
nous venons de loin parce que parfois
des bonnes décisions n'avaient pas été
pris suffisamment tôt parce que le monde
tel qu'ils s'organisent aussi accélérer
les phénomènes de concentration
la métropolisation qui n'est pas le fait
de décisions quel que soit d'ailleurs
des majorités mais qui s'observe partout
dans le monde qui est le regroupement
des talents d énergie dans quelques
villes quelques pôles d'attractivité
mais qui a parfois été aidé par le
concentration autour de grandes régions
de capitale régionale et les
concentrations à paris ou dans ce
capital la de certains de nos choix nous
arrivons donc à un moment critique mais
je ne crois pas là aussi qui est
fatalité et je veux être jugé sur les
actes les actes c'est une augmentation
de la couverture numérique du territoire
inédite
quatorze mille lignes de fibres optiques
sont tirés chaque jour ouvré depuis
janvier 2010 9,4 millions par an nous
serons donc au rendez-vous du haut débit
pour tous en 2020 et du très haut débit
pour tous en 2022 comme je m'y étais
engagé en juillet 2017
les actes c'est l'ouverture des 460
premier france service en janvier 2020
2000 nouveaux cafés dans nos petites
villes d'ici quelques mois dans le cadre
de l'agenda rural les actes c'est la
transformation en cours des logements
des centres villes et des quartiers le
choix résolu de privilégier le commerce
de proximité pour revitaliser les centre
villes les actes
ce sont les 42 quartier de reconquête
républicaine qui bénéficient de renforts
policiers spécifiques les actes c'est ce
travail quotidien résolu pour faire en
sorte que chaque terre de francs soit
une chance pour celles et ceux qui
vivent par plus de stages proposés par
les emplois francs développé par une
nouvelle ambition donner à l' agence
nationale pour la rénovation urbaine
avec des délais raccourcis et de
nouveaux engagements en termes
d'investissements que j'avais pris
les actes et cela c'est en train de se
déployer
cela va continuer d'arriver et c'est une
transformation indispensable mais ça
veut dire que collectivement ce que nous
avons à faire c'est réinventer notre
territoire il n'y a en la matière pas de
fatalité
comme je le disais les métropoles sont
là ce à quoi nous avons à travailler
beaucoup des mères qui soit à la tête de
ces métropoles ou dans leur périphérie
de save
c'est une nouvelle coopération entre ces
territoires par ses décisions prises
mais aussi par les décisions qui sont
prises au sein des structures
intercommunales comme entraîne pour
permettre une mobilité plus adapté pour
apporter les réponses en termes de
pouvoir d'achat à celles et ceux qui
travaillent dans ces métropoles mais
souvent ne peuvent pas et vivre et nous
avons entendu là aussi ce message cette
réinvention de notre territoire
collectivement c'est la capacité que
nous devons donner dans nos quartiers
les plus difficiles les plus pauvres à
accéder aux meilleures formations ce que
nous sommes en train de faire à
l'égalité de la formation supérieure à
l'emploi sans stigmatisation
ce qui est aussi de les réinventer
permettent d'en tirer toute l'énergie
parce qu'ils ont une ressource c'est la
vitalité démographique c'est de
réinventer par le télétravail les
mobilités que vous portez et les projets
innovants j'y reviendrai des
coopérations dans le rural c'est lara
dynamisation de nos centres villes qui
ont été désertés totalement par les
commerces parfois les habitants parce
que des choix ont été opérées dans les
années 80 et 90 qui ont conduit au fond
a séparés notre espace selon les usages
les gens ne veulent plus c'est aussi au
titre de cela qu'ils mais j'ai été
conduits à refuser certains projets que
je ne considérait plus comme du jour le
temps et à la redéfinition de l'espace
et d'un commun nos concitoyens peuvent
vite veulent vivre près de l'endroit où
ils travaillent pouvoir plus facilement
travailler là où ils vivent pouvoir
pouvoir plus facilement accéder à un
commerce de proximité de nouvelles
formes de contact
la culture ils ne veulent plus cet
espace séparé selon les temps où l'on
dort à un endroit on va travailler à un
autre où l'accès à la culture est
ailleurs et c'est d'ailleurs cohérent
avec eux le projet écologique que
collectivement nous poursuivons il nous
faut donc retisser cela va prendre du
temps
ça dépend de votre engagement de la
carte et de nos choix et des instruments
qui sont mises à votre disposition
mais je crois très profondément que par
toutes ces initiatives prises et j'aurai
pu citer encore beaucoup d'autres celle
des territoires d'industrie car là aussi
nous sommes en train de reconquérir
notre industrie pour la première fois
depuis 12 ans nous recréons dans notre
pays de l'emploi industriel nous
rouvrons des usines dans des endroits
qu'ils avaient délaissé ce qu'il n'ya
pas de fatalité il ya des projets qu'on
doit vous aider à porter des
investissements qu'il faut faciliter et
des règles lorsqu'elles sont plus
claires au niveau national qui permette
enfin de réinvestir de réembaucher plus
de cinq cent mille emplois créés en deux
ans ça aussi c'est pour cette ambition
des territoires et donc cet aménagement
nouveau de notre territoire
il est à construire à travers ses
projets ses nouveaux instruments et une
ambition qui nous permettra de bâtir les
nouvelles formes du vivre ensemble de
l'habiter du déplacement et du travail
dans une puissance économique solidaire
et environnemental du 21e siècle celle
que nous voulons bâtir unir et
rassembler c'est notre viatique c'est
aussi tenir la cohésion du pays dans les
dures épreuves des temps vous avez
rappelé les événements tragiques se de
c'est aussi que nous avons vécu ces
derniers mois ces dernières semaines ces
événements qu'il s'agisse du terrorisme
des attaques des violences urbaines ont
touché à chaque fois au premier chef
vous savez ô combien madame la maire de
paris les maires que vous êtes
ces événements en basculer bousculer
notre pays charriant les peurs les
angoisses les tensions et parfois
d'ailleurs laissant monter l'esprit 18
de division et les confusions face à de
tel enchaînement notre responsabilité
collective et de ne jamais jouer sur les
peurs de ne jamais rien céder au n
d'éviter aussi la précipitation
parfois pour apporter les bonnes
réponses opposées au tourbillon des
amalgames la sérénité claire des
principes républicains
faire en sorte que le fils du dialogue
entre les français jamais ne seront à ce
titre je veux dire ici combien les mots
on tue les maires de chacune des
communes concernées par les événements
que je rappelais ont sonné juste qu'ils
étaient à chaque fois frappé d'un grand
sens de la république et de son unité
mais les mots ne puisse pas ce que doit
être notre réaction collective face au
regain des passions de la division et de
la haine
ce qui nous revient de bâtir c'est la
république en actes qui unit les
français
tout simplement parce que la loi
s'applique à tous est en tout point du
territoire
aussi devons-nous travailler ensemble
pour assurer la sécurité de tous nos
concitoyens au quotidien lutter contre
les incivilités la délinquance la
violence qui mine au premier chef la
cohésion du pays je sais que c'est votre
engagement premier là aussi parce qu'à
chaque fois vous ne sollicitez vous
proposait d'ailleurs bien souvent
nous prenons depuis deux ans et demi nos
responsabilités en la matière avec une
volonté forte des policiers et des
gendarmes plus nombreux sur la voie
publique c'est l'engagement de
recrutement de dix mille postes
supplémentaires
les premiers qui sortent de formation
sont en train d'arriver sur le terrain
et les vrais ils sont particulièrement
nombreux dans ces quartiers de
reconquête républicaine où l'effort est
mis en priorité mais c'est aussi dégager
du temps sur le terrain pour nos
policiers et nos gendarmes en
investissant dans la procédure pénale
numérique en elle les jantes ce qui a
été fait dans le cadre de la loi justice
les tâches administratives
c'est aussi le choix qui a été fait
après des années sans que le sujet ne
soit jamais ouvert de décider du
paiement des heures supplémentaires des
policiers parce que les heures payées
c'est plus de présence sur le terrain
c'est donc du temps utile pour vous cet
effort se poursuivra il est
indispensable et c'est notre engagement
mais et vous le savez aussi la sécurité
du quotidien dépend de vous de la
qualité des coopérations entre la police
nationale et municipale entre les
préfets et les élus que vous êtes
et de poursuivre ce travail amplement
engagé nous avons à ce titre d'ailleurs
obtenu des avancées réelles grâce à
l'initiative des parlementaires
je pense en particulier à cette loi sur
les rodéos élaborer ensemble et qui
permet aujourd'hui de saisir les
véhicules et qui permet lorsque le
travail est fait en partenariat sur le
terrain d'agir beaucoup plus
efficacement dans 3 cas sur 4 police
municipale les forces de sécurité
intérieures sont liés par une charte de
coopération qui organise échanges
d'information partage de moyens
techniques et numérique formation et
parfois même patrouilles communes mais
là aussi nous pouvons encore faire
davantage faire mieux
c'est pourquoi je demande au
gouvernement d'étudier toutes les
propositions qui sont faites par les
différentes associations pour améliorer
ce qu'on appelle parfois le continuum de
sécurité c'est à dire la mobilisation de
tous les acteurs forces de l'ordre
police municipale agents techniques
aussi parfois différentes mairies force
et sociétés de sécurité privées pour
agir de manière encore plus efficace
contre les incivilités la délinquance et
poursuivre le travail des propositions
très concrètes ont été faites par
plusieurs d'entre vous et je souhaite
que l'on puisse regarder avancer
certains fichiers pourraient être mieux
partagée je le sais bien
ceux des véhicules volés par exemple on
pourrait agir plus efficacement et plus
concrètement regarder si certains
pouvoirs de police ne pourrait pas être
déléguée dans certains cas les dépôts la
verbalisation des poids lourds il ya des
choses très concrètes que vous appelez
de vos voeux qui permettrait d'ailleurs
non pas à l'état de se désengager je le
dis ici clairement pour lever toute
ambiguïté mais de mieux coopérer et de
permettre aux maires qui le souhaitent
de faire davantage plus efficacement
plus simplement le gouvernement sera au
rendez vous et ces propositions auront
donc une réponse mais au-delà de cette
sécurité du quotidien de ces incivilités
il y a bien entendu ce que notre pays
continue de vivre le terrorisme et le
sujet de la radicalisation qui aussi
appelle une action conjointe
j'ai évoqué il ya quelques semaines la
nécessité de bâtir une société de
vigilance c'est à dire la mobilisation
de tous pour lutter contre ces reculs
insidieux de la république qui trop
souvent se transforme en drame vigilant
en vérité nous le sommes déjà ensemble
150 sharks ont ainsi été signés dans
l'ensemble des communes concernées par
des individus suivi pour radicalisation
est depuis un an sous l'impulsion du
ministre de l'intérieur
comme je m'y étais engagé devant vous
les maires ont désormais droit d'en
connaître le préfet vous informe
régulièrement de l'état de la menace et
peut vous transmettre des éléments
nominatif confidentielles là encore
comment ne pas voir que vous êtes vous
les maires en permanence au contact et
donc les mieux placés aussi bien souvent
pour percevoir les signes faible d'une
dégradation de la situation d'un
glissement est donc être des acteurs à
part entière de cette société de
vigilance c'est à dire une société de la
tension collectif et donc de l'action
est taillé communes sont les bras armé
d'une république qui protège une
république qui avance aussi et s'impose
dans chaque hall d'immeuble dans chaque
rue dans chaque terre de france bien
évidemment
évoquant ces sujets je ne peux bien
entendu rester silencieux sur la
question du communautarisme de
l'islamisme politique temps évoqué ces
dernières semaines et ces derniers mois
dans notre pays je ne veux rien cacher
ici de la réalité que beaucoup d'entre
vous vivent dans certaines communes dans
certains quartiers progresse depuis
quelques années un projet de séparation
d'avec la république
c'est une réalité ce sont les
revendications sur les horaires réservés
aux femmes dans les piscines
ces espaces publics où la mixité n'est
plus possible
ce sont ces pressions exercées dans
certains services publics
certaines entreprises se sont aussi des
services communautaires qui cherchent à
se substituer à la république et les
déscolarisation d'enfants auxquels on
assiste dans trop d'écoles à chaque fois
les maires sont en première ligne l'état
agit et continuera d'agir
nous n'avons pas attendu ces dernières
semaines et les débats qui parfois ont
pu voir le jour
non les lois ont été prises et les
actions ont été conduites en la matière
avec efficacité tout particulièrement
par le ministre de l'intérieur et le
ministre de l'éducation nationale grâce
là aussi à des initiatives
parlementaires salutaire sur ce sujet
douze lieux de culte ont ainsi été
fermés
quatre écoles hors contrat neuf
établissements associatifs
près de 130 débits de boissons toujours
avec la coopération des mères cette
action continuera d'être menée
et nous devons là aussi faire plus ne
jamais vous laisser isoler dans ce qui
est un des grands combats républicains
contemporain tout le gouvernement est
mobilisé et continuera d'agir
le ministre de l'intérieur donnera des
instructions nouvelles aux préfets dans
les prochains jours en la matière et le
gouvernement portera des actions
concrètes nouvelles dans les prochaines
semaines sur ce sujet mais là aussi je
veux nous appeler collectivement à ne
pas tout confondre
dans les débats qui souvent se nouent
sur ces sujets compliqués on confond
tour on confond bien souvent la laïcité
la civilité et l'ordre public la laïcité
là un cadre la loi de 1905
il a été complété par des lois que
récentes importantes qui ont été le
fruit d'ailleurs de longues
concertations
c'est un cadre un cadre de liberté le
respect la liberté de croire et de ne
pas croire c'est un cadre de neutralité
ça n'est en aucun cas un cadre de
combats ou d'exclusion
ça n'est pas la notion qui doit nous
conduire à mettre dos à dos feront un
front une part de la société française
contraignant
ce serait une profonde erreur historique
est une faute lourde politique la
laïcité est là ce cadre faisons le
appliquez la respectons le partout c'est
à cela que j'appelle le gouvernement
mais bien souvent ceux qui traversent
notre société ce sont les sujets que je
viens d'évoquer légitime qui touche la
civilité l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
les le respect des lois de la république
l'ordre public et c'est là qu'il nous
faut collectivement nous réarmer
peut-être 30 des lois nouvelles des
décisions plus forte mais le confondons
pas tout faisons le avec la source de la
république il n'y jamais avec l'esprit
de division
il est inefficace et produit le pire est
donc le gouvernement sera au rendez-vous
de cette ambition en suivant ces
principes
et puis ça vous touche tout
particulièrement dans les débats récents
un sujet est venu celui des listes
communautaire
je suis sur ce point pragmatique et
ouvert à toutes les propositions à la
condition qu'elle soit efficace et que
là aussi elle respecte nos principes
d'abord vous êtes je pense toutes et
tous attachés à ce qui fait notre vie
politique qui est aussi un principe de
liberté
comment définir et on les listes
communautaire qui en serait le juge
selon quels critères
la vie politique est ainsi fait que les
choses peuvent changer
nous avons des règles claires
faut-il ici les bousculer parce que
soudain les esprits s'échauffent je nous
appelle collectivement à la prudence pas
la prudence qui mène à l'inaction non
celle qui conduit à ne pas renoncer aux
libertés de la république parce que le
pire est parfois là celle qui nous
conduit aussi à voir toutes les
conséquences de ce qu'on propose
et puis surtout il ne faut pas en la
matière à voir quelques naïvetés que ce
soit il ne s'agit pas de proclamer
l'interdiction pour régler le problème
nous avons eu dans d'autres temps de la
république ces débats fallait-il
interdire des listes anti sémite pour
réussir à chasser ces idées de la
société française
qui peut penser d'ailleurs que de telles
listes se présenteront à visage
découvert avec spontanéité et clarté
non si les choses étaient si simple nous
n'aurions pas tant de difficultés ceux
d'entre vous qui sont confrontés à ces
phénomènes le savent ceux qui
développent un projet communautariste
cet islam politique que j'ai évoqué un
projet de division de la nation en
détournant une religion de ses
fondements très souvent se cache se
dissimule c'est là toute la difficulté
est donc ce qui compte c'est le combat
politique en actes ce qui compte c'est
l'intransigeance républicaine quand la
prééminence de nos lois et remise en
question quand l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes est combattue
remise en cause
ce qui compte c'est de faire tomber les
masques de ceux qui combattent la devise
inscrite sur les frontons des mairies
qu'il convoite
et ce combat je sais que je peux compter
sur vous pour le mener sur tous les
maires de france pour le mener pour
l'emporter et je vais vous dire une
chose vous pourrez compter sur moi mais
en actes au quotidien chaque jour pour
les débusquer les combattre fermez les
associations fermer les écoles quand
elles ne respectent pas absolument les
lois de la république
c'est ainsi qu'il faut mener ce combat
je ne crois pas autrement
et donc là aussi sur ce sujet le
gouvernement poursuivra avec l'ensemble
des forces politiques de notre pays le
travail pour rassembler les meilleures
idées avancées et agir
mesdames et messieurs préparant ma venue
parmi vous je relisais aussi l'histoire
des congrès des maires de france et ce
faisant l'histoire des maires de france
et je me faisais cette réflexion toute
simple en quelque sorte quand on reprend
à la cavalcade cette odyssée commune
depuis la révolution française
à chaque fois qu'il a fallu bâtir la
république ces grands projets et
construire son avenir
cela s'est fait dans et à travers par
les maires la liberté la république et
la démocratie 9d la révolution française
la construction de la république dès les
lois de 71 72 d'abord par les conseils
départementaux puis quatre en dix par la
loi de 1884 par le rôle qu'on donne au
maire et à la construction de notre
école de la république de nos écoles
dans chaque commune
bien souvent aussi des infrastructures
s'est faite par ce truchement et la
solidité de notre république a su bâtir
entre la défaite de 70 et 1914 c'est ce
moment inouï où la république a su
construire une espèce de pacte
d'ambition et de contrôle réciproque
avec les élus locaux et ceux de la
république permettent que rien ne soit
remis en cause si le pire devait advenir
à paris avec les pouvoirs donnés des 71
et 72 au niveau du département
en 84 communes et permettre d'avancer
avec des projets concrets la solidité de
notre pays elle procède de de ce temps
incroyable et à chaque moment que la
république a été bousculé par des doutes
par le pire parfois bousculés en son
sommet elle a su retrouver ce socle
cette action concrète cette stabilité
des valeurs et des principes auprès de
sa mère et il en est de même dans le
moment que nous vivons nous sommes dans
un moment particulier notre pays mais il
suffit de regarder autour de nous pour
nous apercevoir que nous sommes dans un
moment historique pour toutes les
démocraties occidentales au fond pour le
monde entier
un moment de doute de crise regarder
autour de nous qui a un gouvernement
stable
une majorité claire qui a une vie
démocratique innocente
placide je cherche et paradis les
exemples je n'en trouve pas c'est bien
parce que nous avons collectivement de
nouveaux défis à relever c'est que nous
vivons la fin aussi d'une époque de
transformation profonde
peut-être que nous n'avons pas toujours
su prendre à temps mais aussi des défis
contemporains qui agitent les peurs le
défi technologique
le défi climatique le défi démographique
et la brutalité de ce monde contemporain
pour réussir ces transformations
comme à chaque fois que la république a
été confronté à ces grandes bourrasques
j'ai besoin de vous et c'est ensemble
que nous bâtirons cette action utile
c'est aussi pour cela
fort de ce temps passé ensemble de ces
mois de débats de commune en commune
mais aussi de cette conviction chevillée
au corps et inspirés par notre histoire
que cet acte 2 comme je les appelais du
mandat qui m'a été confié par les
français je n'ai voulu le bâtir autour
de quelques sujets ou votre rôle est
déterminant
je ne couvrirait pas tous mais je veux
ici simplement mentionné 2 le premier
vous l'avez évoqué un instant c'est
celui de la transition écologique de
l'environnement elle se joue bien sûr
sur le plan international la france est
au rendez vous
dans les négociations entre états sur
les baisses des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre la préservation de la
biodiversité la constitution d'un droit
environnemental contraignant et vous
savez l'engagement de la france sur tous
ces sujets elle se joue en europe et
vous savez combien la france porte une
ambition climatiques et
environnementales entre union européenne
elle se joue aussi au niveau national
est là également le gouvernement prend
ses responsabilités je connais peu de
pays qui ont assumé la fermeture de
toutes leurs centrales à charbon la fin
de l'exploitation des hydrocarbures
un plan pour la biodiversité ça a été
fait et c'est en train de s'appliquer
et ce n'est qu'un début de l'action qui
est en train d'être conduite et la
convention citoyenne cher président qui
est en train de travailler au sérieux en
ce moment-même proposera gouvernement à
moi-même nouvelles actions concrètes qui
scanderont notre travail collectif dans
les prochains mois mais en vérité
là aussi c'est bien dans les territoires
et par les communes que la transition se
fait concrètement la protection des
espaces la lutte contre la pollution aux
usa comme déchets et donc le combat pour
la biodiversité c'est vous les plans
pour décarbonés des transports pour
rénover les logements et donc emporté la
bataille de la baisse des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et du climat
c'est vous bien sûr l'état doit fixer un
cadre une direction donnée des
instruments mais ensuite c'est aux
communes qu'il importe de faire très
souvent et c'est d'ailleurs là que les
initiatives les plus innovantes
bien souvent ont été prises
les maires ont un rôle clé ils ont aussi
une connaissance du terrain de ses
contraintes et parfois des tensions que
ces sujets peuvent faire naître amer sur
cinq est agriculteur ou ancien
agriculteur
ce qui donne une expérience
et je dois le dire aussi bien souvent
quelques bons sens cette transition et
les complexes et là aussi on voit qu'il
ya des intéressés dans la salle c'est
statistiquement normalement vérifier
cette trame des territoires elle
implique du bon sens et là aussi de
savoir gérer les choses sans je dirais
conflits inutiles ce rôle en matière
d'écologie
je commencerai par là ne doit pas
conduire ne doit pas vous conduire à
prendre des décisions qui ne relèvent
pas du pouvoir de police du maire la
toxicité d'un produit chimique
ce n'est pas la compétence du maire et
je vais vous dire c'est une bonne chose
pour vous quand je vois des mères qui
prennent des arrêtés pour interdire des
pesticides dans leur commune quel sens
ça est-ce que la toxicité de pesticides
elle ne serait pas la même à plougastel
ou à morlaix aucun sens aucun sens il ya
peut-être plus de fraises d'un côté que
de l'autre c'est vrai et donc c'est pour
vous protéger
os x pouvoir n'est pas donner sinon ce
sera la guérilla terrible et surtout
l'incompréhension généralisée et donc en
la matière j'en appelle à la modération
mais au-delà de cela vous avez un rôle
essentiel et je veux lui aussi apporter
quelques clarifications si nous voulons
aussi nous voulons aller plus loin nous
devons bâtir avec vous sur les
territoires des filières d'économie
circulaire luttant activement contre le
gaspillage en la matière vous avez
d'ailleurs bien souvent prix ou même des
décisions
c'est pour cela que sur ce sujet et sur
un sujet particulièrement sensible comme
celui de la consigne des bouteilles
plastiques
rien ne sera fait sans l'accord des
maires c'est bien dans ce sens
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien dans ce sens que j'ai demandé
au gouvernement de poursuivre le
dialogue au parlement conforter ceux qui
ont pris de l'avancé investi et des
faire parce que nous devons avoir une
réponse forte et ambitieuse en la
matière
nos concitoyens attendent mais on ne
doit pas pénaliser ceux qui sont
organisés parfois il ya plusieurs années
et ont pris des investissements utiles
et ceux qui ont trouvé la bonne
organisation
ça doit donc passer par une
indispensable concertation oui je crois
à une écologie de la liberté de
l'innovation je crois dans l'écologie
des territoires et la capacité qu'on
donne à ces derniers de trouver les
bonnes solutions
je crois dans ceux d'entre vous qui
innovent pour préserver les espaces
naturels et agricoles planter des forêts
urbaines encourager la conversion des
exploitations agricoles vers le bio et
la haute valeur environnementale qui
développe des plans alimentaires
territoriaux pour april approvisionner
les écoles et les marchés en circuit
court dans ceux d'entre vous qui
développe massivement des transports en
commun propres
le bus à hydrogène les nouvelles
solutions pour remplacer la voiture
les véhicules en autopartage les
navettes y compris dans le rural et les
pôles des changes qui pense la ville du
vélo de la marche à pied dans ceux qui
inventent les réseaux intelligents qui
permettront d'intégrer des énergies
renouvelables par essence intermittentes
dans les systèmes électriques des villes
qui investissent pour la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments municipaux des
logements tout ce que je viens de dire
est en train de se faire et la loi
d'orientation pour les mobilités
largement concertée donne aux régions un
rôle très important et aux communes un
rôle à leurs côtés et c'est donc un
cadre des instruments une clarté de
financement mais là aussi nous sommes en
train de de construire cette écologie
concrètes
vous êtes en train de le faire ce qu'on
doit apporter c'est le cadre clair les
responsabilités ce que permet la loi
d'orientation et
les financements pour la compagnie les
contrats de transition énergétique
permettent dans certaines situations
difficile de le faire la clarté qui sera
donné sur les dotations qui accompagne
la loi en sera une autre et je souhaite
que les prochains mois soient scandés
par de nouveaux appels à projets pour
accompagner très clairement
tous ces projets aussi que je viens
d'évoquer dans le cadre et larchitecture
de la loi qui a été largement concertée
et qui sera de manière imminente
ainsi voté l'écologie du quotidien
l'écologie concrètes l'écologie
française c'est celle de nos territoires
celle en action
c'est pourquoi là aussi je crois très
profondément comme lorsque la république
a eu bête a eu à bâtir son école votre
rôle est indispensable
le deuxième sujet sur lequel je voulais
attirer votre attention et vous dire
combien
au fond nous avons aujourd'hui pour
mener cette action besoin de vous c'est
celui de la république sociale solidaire
de ceux solidarisme contemporains
auxquels je crois profondément dans
votre quotidien vous êtes confrontés et
vous avez apporté nombre de ses missions
bien souvent d'ailleurs en lien avec les
départements qui en la matière joue un
rôle essentiel
cher président vous avez à vous occuper
des personnes éloignées de l'emploi avec
les missions locales celles en situation
de difficulté ponctuelle ou durable avec
les ccas l'accompagnement des personnes
âgées les situations liées justement aux
demandes d'asile et aux migrations que
sur beaucoup de nos territoires nous
connaissons tous ces sujets sont majeurs
je n'y reviendrai pas vous êtes aussi au
coeur d'une ambition économique
indispensable mais il ya deux politiques
deux actions sociales indispensables à
notre république et à la construction de
cette république solidaire du 21e siècle
où votre rôle est décisif c'est l'école
et la santé
le sujet qui à mes yeux caractérise
l'état providence du 21e siècle que nous
sommes en train collectivement de bâtir
auxquels je crois profondément qui est
celui où l'on investit sur les personnes
à celui où on administre les choses non
mais on décide d'investir sur nos
concitoyens pour les aider à choisir
leur vie à la bâtir là où ils sont et là
votre rôle comme il l'a toujours été et
éminent l'éducation vous savez
l'ambition qui est la nôtre
merci président de l'avoir rappelé elle
est partagée elle m'a conduit d'ailleurs
parfois là aussi à corriger des choses
qui étaient faites je le disais
tellement partagé que je me suis engagé
à ce qu'aucune école ne soit fermé sans
l'accord du maire et depuis que j'ai
pris cet engagement c'est ce qui a été
fait par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale avec une grande vigilance qui
l'a encore rappelé priorité donnée à
l'école primaire parce que c'est là que
se nouent les inégalités réforme du
lycée réforme de l'orientation
jamais on n'a vu en si peu de temps sauf
à revenir à 7 ans inauguraux de la
république que je rappeler tout à
l'heure les investissements et de tels
changements
je sais aussi des inquiétudes comment
financer les aides scènes
supplémentaires face à l'augmentation
des effectifs induite par l'école
obligatoire dès 3 ans comment prendre en
charge les dépenses immobilières liées
ou dédoublement des classes de cp ce1
ce2 le sujet des grandes sections
maternelles
je veux ici rassurer je sais les
discussions en cours
vous aurez l'occasion d'y revenir avec
le ministre l'état accompagné à hauteur
d'un peu plus d'une dizaine de millions
d'euros
et c'est vrai pas la totalité qui a été
investie et je remercie toutes les
communes qui ont beaucoup fait sur le
sujet et nous continueront d'accompagner
et là aussi ce dialogue continuera de se
faire parce que nous avons besoin de
cette ambition collective parce que nos
enfants pour pouvoir bâtir leur vie ont
besoin d'une école
ainsi construite avec moins d'élèves par
classe et avec les réformes qui ont
honte
ainsi était décidée parce que aussi nous
avons besoin pour ré attirer des
familles dans certains endroits dans
certains quartiers ou dans une part de
notre ruralité de leur offrir des écoles
de qualité
c'est ça l'objet de réformes nous
travaillons également ensemble
installé dans tous les territoires de
france dcf à de nouvelles antennes du
cnam des unités d'enseignement supérieur
comme ces campus connectés dans
l'objectif est de permettre à des
étudiants habitant dans des territoires
éloignés des grandes villes de
bénéficier d'une offre complète de
formation ce que nous allons déployer
dans les prochains mois ce que j'ai
demandé au gouvernement de faire c'est à
rebours de ce que vous avez bien souvent
vue d'ouvrir dans des villes moyennes
qui n'ont pas aujourd'hui d'université
pas de formation supérieure des antennes
d'université certaines formations
professionnelles ou académique et
parfois les deux pour permettre de se
former au plus près de chez soi et
répondre se faisant aussi à des
problèmes bien souvent de mobilité de
coûts du logement dans les métropoles de
rareté du foncier que nous avons à vivre
par ailleurs c'est là aussi ce projet
d'aménagement du territoire que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure qui est un
pragmatisme que nous déclinons pour
l'ambition scolaire l'école de la
république celle de jules ferry qui est
enraciné dans chaque terre de france 7
historiquement construite dans ce main
dans la main entre le gouvernement et
les maires et c'est ce fils qu'il nous
faut tisser encore et encore et puis le
second pilier de cette république
sociale c'est la santé là aussi vous
n'avez pas attendu le gouvernement sur
ce sujet je dois bien le dire
j'avais envoyé au moment du grand débat
des questions mais celle qui est le plus
remonté et de très loin
spontanément à chaque fois c'est la
santé disant d'ailleurs l'urgence de
notre hymne organisation collective et
des errements de plusieurs décennies
déserts médicaux d'un côté
surpopulation dans les urgences de
l'autre centre hospitalier
professionnels qui n'arrivent plus à
faire face à la demande sur certains
territoires disparition dans d'autres
c'est le fruit là aussi deux dogmes qui
ont longtemps vécu on dépensera moins
six à moins de médecins
bizarrement les gens n'ont pas été moins
malade et donc nous voilà avec un
système de santé sur lequel il faut tout
à la fois réinvestir mais qu'il faut
aussi réorganiser je veux saluer ici
l'engagement que depuis plusieurs années
vous avez pris avec beaucoup de
conviction pour développer des réseaux
porter des projets ouvrir des structures
engagement que j'avais pris devant vous
c'est d'accompagner cela pour doubler
les maisons de santé
c'est ce qui sera fait et nous sommes
sur cet objectif
l'engagement c'est aussi pour répondre à
vos besoins
une réforme plus en profondeur qui a été
annoncé il ya un an dans le cadre du
plan masanté 2022 et qu'il avoue touche
directement la suppression du numerus
clausus mais ça touchera nos successeurs
parce qu'on met dix ans au moins en
forme et un médecin mais de l'ecti
vivement nous devons agir pour l'avenir
le recrutement de 600 médecins salariés
que nous commençons à déployer dans les
territoires les plus carence est dès à
présent le développement de la
télémédecine le renforcement du rôle des
infirmiers l'ouverture de 1000 maisons
de santé comme je le disais et
l'encouragement à vos côtés de ces
maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires en
finançant ses assistants médicaux pour
encourager les professionnels à venir et
faire que les projets immobiliers que
vous avez souvent porté bas soit
accompagnée par des projets médicaux et
que ces derniers soit est d aider en
leur payant
cette assistante médicale qui vient cet
assistant médical qui vient l'heure les
décharges et d'actes médicaux et leur
permettre de mieux travailler sur vos
territoires
là aussi rien ne se fera sans vous il ya
des formidables succès j'étais quelques
jours je le disais dans la marne deux
maisons de santé en 2009
quatorze aujourd'hui trois de plus qui
sont en projet j'ai vu des projets
formidables en gironde ou municipalité
ars centre hospitalier agissent ensemble
pour créer un centre hospitalo communal
à pontarlier dans le doubs
cher président non loin de chez vous des
acteurs locaux qui savent s'organiser
pour mettre en place un cabinet éphémère
le temps justement que de nouveaux
médecins s'installent plus rapidement en
saône et loire par la volonté d'un
conseil départemental tout un réseau de
santé de proximité se mettre en place et
des médecins revenir exercer dans les
villes désertées
c'est ça ce que nous accompagnons
complètement concrètement et que nous
allons déployer plus fortement encore et
donc le gouvernement là aussi sera au
rendez vous pour mettre les moyens
et pour en rajouter je ne veux pas ici
déflorer les annonces que le premier
ministre la ministre des solidarités de
la santé feront demain en la matière
mais il est clair que l'urgence impose
d'investir plus fortement encore et de
construire une plus grande attractivité
de nos hôpitaux qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
eu centre universitaire ou parfois plus
en proximité pour réussir à mener ce
combat je voulais aussi vous dire
l'engagement du gouvernement mais le
rôle aussi essentiel que vous jouez
mesdames et messieurs chers amis j'ai
conscience
une fois que j'ai dit tout cela de la
difficulté des temps et vous l'avez
rappelé et je veux conclure mon propos
en vous lisant aussi un mot de vous j'ai
à mon tour
en cet instant une pensée pour jean
mathieu michel le maire de signes qui a
consacré sa vie à sa commune
vous le disiez président tout à l'heure
en rappelant son engagement 83 pour
finalement mourir dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions dans le courage de sa fonction
c'est justement de faire respecter la
vie en commun de rappeler à l'ordre ceux
qui
dans sa commune venez enfreindre la
règle les sinois et les sinois
n'oublierons jamais ce grand humaniste
qui les connaissaient tous
personnellement et je veux avoir une
pensée pour eux pour le personnel de la
commune et pour sa famille dont la
dignité fut exemplaire en cet instant
cette tragédie ainsi que les dizaines
d'agressions dont les maires et les élus
locaux ces derniers mois beaucoup trop
d'élus la république ont été victimes
appelle la république et chacun de ce
citoyen ses devoirs et la république je
le redis ici nous doit protection la
république ne peut en effet vous
demandez temps sans assurer votre
sécurité et en particulier celles et
ceux d'entre vous qui craignent pour
leur intégrité physique
elle ne peut vous demander temps non
plus sans vous donner les moyens de
l'action
et là aussi c'est l'objet de ce texte de
loi proposé par les ministres défendu en
ce moment même à l'assemblée nationale
qui est le fruit du grand débat qui est
le fruit des propositions concrètes des
maires de france de leur pragmatisme d
indignation que j'ai récolté des
interpellations que j'ai reçu d'abord en
reconnaissant et en soutenant davantage
votre engagement
l'engagement c'est la sève une nation ce
qu'il a fait ce qui la tient ce qu'il a
grandi l'engagement associatif syndical
politique est bien entendu l'engagement
des mères ça fait des décennies qu'on
parle du statut de l'élu des décennies
alors il ya des débats et je veux
reconnaître au gouvernement de porter
enfin une réforme tant et tant attendu
le projet de loi engagement et proximité
discuter encore ces dernières heures à
l'assemblée nationale s'inspire de
toutes ces idées et donc oui ce texte
vous permettra de bénéficier d'une
protection juridique dans le cadre de
l'exercice de vos fêtes devant fonctions
et nous l'assumons
oui
vous bénéficierez désormais d'un droit à
la formation et nous l'assumons
oui les élus locaux pourront mieux
concilier leur vie personnelle et leur
vie familiale avec par exemple le
remboursement des frais de garde et nous
l'assumons
oui les maires ruraux qui dans les
campagnes de france sont bien souvent
tout à la fois policiers médecins
urbanisme jardinier assistant social
seront rétribués aussi alors juste
niveau d'engagement et nous l'assumons
entre autres choses je veux le dire ici
parce que c'est une première
mais votre moteur je sais je le sais
parce que je suis fait comme vous je
démontrais c'est de faire de transformer
d'agir
c'est pourquoi le projet de loi renforce
aussi vos marges d'action
je ne reviens pas sur les marges
d'action financière va commencer à
aborder vous y reviendrez avec le
gouvernement non je veux évoquer les
moyens d'action juridique que vous
revendiquez légitimement il ya d'abord
tout ce qui bride les normes qui vous
enserre l'intercommunalité qui parfois
vous freine vous avez un modèle de la
souplesse j'ai le même et pour moi aussi
rassurez vous ça va trop lentement et
lorsque je suis allé et quelques jours
dans la marne j'ai réuni d'ailleurs lé
préfet et chefs de service de l'état
déconcentré pour faire la revue de
chantier en la matière mais ça avance
les normes nous en réduisons d'abord le
flux on regarde trop peu souvent 40
projets de décret pris par les
ministères en deux ans et demi
c'était 100 par an avant s'emparant le
stock
les fameuses circulaire vous savez ces
lois qui ne sont pas discutées au
parlement et c'est écrit qu'ils sont pas
pris par les ministres mais tout ce qui
fait la vie de l'administration et qui à
la fin vous et parfois opposées ces
circulaires 65% des circulaires
existantes abrogée je peux vous dire que
ce travail de pénélope
il a fallu le porter il touche votre
quotidien ce n'est pas entendu de
protestation ça veut dire qu'elles ne
servaient pas forcément à grand chose ce
travail il faut le poursuivre et là
aussi j'en appelle aux bonnes idées mais
ne sous-estimé pas une chose simplifier
ses complexes parce que supprimer un
texte une circulaire c'est s'assurer
qu'il servait à rien il faut tester les
gens faut le vérifier vous le savez bien
et donc j'ai besoin de vous pour que ce
travail se poursuivent un nouveau
service le rescrit normatif sera créé
dans les préfectures et sera valable dès
le début du mandat prochain et permettra
de sécuriser tous les projets sur le
plan juridique
de la même manière déconcentré la
décision s'est simplifié pour vous on
est plusieurs dans cette salle est
rattachée à cela je le sais plus de
mille procédures administratives ont été
déconcentré au plus près du terrain ça
veut dire quoi que sur ces 1000
décisions multiples de décision là où
bien souvent le préfet le directeur
d'administration locale vous disais je
ne peux pas vous donner la réponse je
dois demander à paris la décision peut
se prendre sur le terrain de manière
concrète c'est plus de responsabilités
plus de rapidité plus aussi de
simplicité de souplesse
l'intercommunalité nous la subissons
répartition des compétences entre les
communes périmètre des opci conseil des
maires tout est mis en place pour toutes
à la fois mieux s'organiser et respecter
les libertés locales
et là aussi les avancées qui émane de ce
débat porter est apte et encore ces
dernières heures nous l'évoquions
ensemble un instant président par le
premier ministre et les ministres
permettront utilement d'avancé et ce
jusqu'au bout
du chemin de ce texte de loi pour que
les maires puissent choisir pour que les
maires élus au suffrage universel ne
puisse jamais être en quelque sorte
simplement les récipiendaires
d'instruction d'une autre collectivité
vous souhaitez aller plus loin encore
dans la souplesse d'organisation
j'y suis prêt de manière là aussi très
complète
alors vous m'avez interpellé sur ce
point monsieur le président je veux y
revenir d'abord pour dire que en la
matière là aussi le texte de loi
c'est sur ce sujet les seules décisions
qui ont été prises par ce gouvernement
et cette majorité
j'entends vos protestations à juste
titre mais il faut pas opposer au
gouvernement ou à vos parlementaires les
décisions de jeudi ce sont quand même
être clair sur ce point
ou alors si témoin les discours où
j'aurais porté de l'intercommunalité
forcée citez moi les discours ou géniez
la force démocratique du maire cité mois
les discours et les actes qui ont fait
le contraire
chers amis il vous est arrivé d'avoir
des prédécesseurs il faut les respecter
vous n'êtes pas obligé de tout prendre
[Applaudissements]
j'en prends déjà assez je considère que
en ce moment collectivement nous prenons
notre part y compris des conséquences
parfois dont les causes ne nous
appartiennent pas totalement
donc continuons d'avancer collectivement
et je veux insister pour vous dire que
le gouvernement est là le parlement est
là et les réponses seront apportées
comme vous l'avez voulu alors maintenant
comment aller plus loin continuez à
déconcentrer
j'y crois très profondément le premier
ministre a annoncé des décisions fortes
plus de 6000 fonctionnaires qui seront
ramenés sur les territoires il faut
poursuivre ce mouvement il faut le
poursuivre en particulier de l'échelon
régional à l'échelon local
c'est indispensable les grandes régions
ont permis parfois de regrouper des
services mais elles ont permis sur
certains sujets où elles ont plutôt
qu'en juillet sur certains sujets à
recréer de la concentration régionale et
à éloigner la décision du terrain c'est
pas une bonne chose et donc le souhaite
de tout l'équipement le gouvernement
parlement puisse avancer sur ce sujet
manière très concrète
on a évoqué avec plusieurs d'entre vous
en matière de logement sur beaucoup
d'autres sujets des décisions qui
étaient parfois prises au niveau
département de son haut niveau de la
région ça n'est pas bon il se dirait
plus le numérique dont on parle le temps
auquel nous tenons qui nous permet de
recréer de l'industrie de développer des
emplois sur notre territoire doit nous
permettre aussi d'être inventif en
matière d'organisation de l'état
pourquoi parce qu'il ya le numérique on
devrait demander à tous nos agents à
tous nos fonctionnaires d'aller dans la
capitale régionale ou à paris pour faire
des travaux d'intérêt général les
expliquer à nos concitoyens vous voulez
joindre aux fonctionnaires internet ou
le téléphone
au contraire on peut laisser ou remettre
des fonctionnaires et des agents sur le
terrain et grâce au numérique leur
permettent de faire des tâches communes
pour le compte de la région ou même plus
largement je crois que c'est beaucoup
plus porteur d'avenir qui plus est bien
souvent dans des territoires où le
déplacement est moins compliqué
le logement moins cher les conditions de
vie plus agréable et donc il nous faut
là aussi reconstruire ses équilibres
nouveau réinventer les choses changer
des habitudes qui avaient été acquises
c'est ce qui a commencé à être fait qui
continuera à l'être avec force et en la
matière le projet france service est
d'ailleurs un levier et croyant en
exigeant sur le sujet
ce ne sera pas un paravent ce sera bien
une ambition nouvelle de la présence des
compétences sur des territoires et de
l'innovation aussi pour tous nos
services comme d'ailleurs pour les
grands partenaires de l'état je pense à
la poste qui peut permettre non pas d'en
france service mais en allant au plus
près nos concitoyens comme elle commence
à le faire en matière de santé pour
apporter du service jusqu'à nos
concitoyens pour lui inventer une
nouvelle mission d'intérêt général dans
nos campagnes les plus isolés ont besoin
dans aussi certains quartiers de la
république certains ont besoin
différenciation c'est le deuxième levier
après la déconcentration nous avons
commencé de le faire beaucoup ont joué
le jeu
ces fameux contrats permettent de mieux
répondre il ya les contrats dits de
coeur que les plus grosses collectivités
ont souvent signés et qui produisent
leurs effets il y a aussi les contrats
de différenciation d'action de la creuse
cher président jusqu'aux ardennes en
passant par la bretagne à tous les
niveaux des contrats ont été signés par
le gouvernement qui ont permis de bâtir
des actions concrètes de projets sur le
terrain de différencier c'est une
manière aussi d'avancer efficace
beaucoup plus forte et je souhaite que
nous puissions franchir un pas
supplémentaire de c'est que nous sommes
beaucoup dans cette salle elle vouloir
par la réforme constitutionnelle qui
permettra d'instaurer un droit à la
différenciation et là je sais compter
sur chacun pour que nous puissions aller
au bout de cette idée et puis la
troisième après la déconcentration la
différenciation c'est la
décentralisation
vous l'avez évoqué et je souhaite que
sur ce sujet nous puissions avancer mais
je vais vous dire quelques convictions
en la matière il y a eu plusieurs vagues
de décentralisation
et essayons collectivement d'en faire le
débat d'en faire le bilan de l oms dans
beaucoup de cas réussi d'avoir à mener
une action plus concrète en effet plus
proche des territoires mais bilan que
j'en tire pour l'état trop souvent
l'état essayé de garder une partie de la
compétence et n'a pas fait toutes les
économies et parfois d'ailleurs nous
avons collectivement perdu de la
compétence prenant les routes
est-ce qu'on est aussi bon sur ce sujet
qui à 40 ans chez patient a su les ponts
on en parle en ce moment est-ce qu'on
est aussi bon pas sûr donc il faut que
la décentralisation s'accompagne de
choix clair du côté de l'état il doit
lâcher toutes les compétences quand ils
les décentralise mais faut pas que cela
conduise à de la perte collective de
connaissance et qu'on ait un seul coup
on se réveille et qu'on se dise là on
n'est plus aussi bon car ensuite on a
parfois décentralisée des compétences
s'en donner les moyens
le rsa et les départements est ce que
c'est de la bonne décentralisation non
on a plusieurs fois évoqué ce fait
maintenant des années quasiment depuis
le premier jour que des débats sans fin
se noue pour savoir si la compensation
est la bonne et qui plus est on à
décentraliser une compétence sur
laquelle la collectivité en charge
n'avait quasiment pas de moyens d'action
ce que c'est de la bonne de
centralisation
moi je veux bien décentralisée des
compétences si la collectivité qui la
reçoit ne peut rien faire et qu'elle est
un payeur aveugle elle dit j'ai la
compétence et donc j'en ai tiré une
conviction simple qui peut être que
rendre les choses parfois plus compliqué
qui ne semble au premier abord quand on
décentralise une compétence faut
décentraliser les moyens clairement et
la dynamique des moyens clermont est ce
qu'il y a sur chacune de ses compétences
une dynamique une fiscalité clair non
vous me parlez du foncier pour les
départements c'est émouvant
mais si le foncier avec avait la même
dynamique que le rsa se seraient vus
depuis longtemps et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'on fait d'été péréquation en
permanence si les départements qui
touchent le plus de foncier et droits de
mutation à titre onéreux et lé
département qui avait
de rsa la france serait plus heureuse
rien à voir il ya une ressource fiscale
elle n'a rien à voir avec la dépense est
ce que c'est de la bonne
décentralisation conviendra avec moque
non c'est ridicule c'est ridicule et
donc on fait de la bricole en permanence
on fait de la péréquation tous les
matins vous savez bien
donc cette émotion me touche mais elle
ne pas répondre n'est pas fait comme si
on veut avancer faut regarder en effet
quel fils qu'elle était au part de
fiscalité on donne aux collectivités en
décentralisant et nous nous avons un
fétichisme français l'autonomie fiscale
je regarde les grands pays décentralisé
autour de nous sont beaucoup plus
décentralisée que nous non pas
d'autonomie fiscale
ils ont ils ont une chambre qui chaque
année en effet discutent des ressources
fiscales qui sont affectés aux
collectivités chaque niveau avec des
éclairs peut-être qu'ils font en alien
en arriver à ça et moi j'y suis
favorable à ce que je vais vous dire
l'autonomie fiscale elle a deux
problèmes la première il n'y a jamais
une fiscalité qui correspond à la bonne
compétence
donc il y aura toujours des péréquations
et de lisibilité c'est vrai les seuls
qui peuvent avoir une fiscalité propre
ce sont les communes ils ont une clause
de compétence générale pour ça que
j'assume le foncier et ne me dites pas
il ya des gens qui sont exonérés qu'ils
payent pas dans la commune de 3 doit y
avoir 70% des gens qui payent pas la
taxe d'habitation on en parlait l'autre
jour pas pour autant qu'il n'y avait
plus de liens avec eux la vie dans la
commune banc donc il y aura jamais la
bonne fiscalité en tout cas pour les
départements les régions
par contre faut qu'il y ait une
dynamique fiscale qui correspondent à la
dynamique des compétences qu'ils aient
une visibilité qui soient données et
c'est vrai que nous sommes pas bons sur
ce sujet et donc est ce qu'on peut
peut-être évoluer dans notre capacité
collective à la fois à moderniser nos
impôts à clarifier les responsabilités
fiscale et de compétences
je l'espère ce que vous savez sinon on
vit dans une société où selon les
niveaux on augmente les impôts d'un côté
on les baisse de l'autre c'est illisible
pour nos concitoyens
qu'est ce qui s'est fait ces dernières
années je parle du mandat précédent
vous l'avez dit des dotations et ed
effet massivement mais c'est de la
fiscalité locale qui a souvent été
augmenté massivement souvent au niveau
intercommunal avec souvent d'ailleurs
des gens qui ne rock qui ne savait plus
qui faisait quoi
est-ce que c'est démocratiquement
souhaitable je vous livre ma conviction
non donc oui à la décentralisation
mais oui à la décentralisation ou les
compétences sont accompagnés d'une
décentralisation claire des financements
qui vont avec
avec la bonne dynamique et la visibilité
si on trouve des mots les morceaux
d'impôts nationaux qui ont cette
dynamique
allons-y si on pense que c'est en
regardant nos voisins qu'il faut le
faire j'y suis favorable et dans ces cas
là c'est un changement constitutionnel
vers lequel il faut peut-être aller je
le dis devant le président du sénat j'y
suis ouvert plus que ça à titre
personnel favorable
[Applaudissements]
et de l'autre côté en décentralisant les
compétences il faut décentraliser les
responsabilités et là aussi on peut pas
dire je prends les compétences mais
quand ya un problème
vous le savez vous quand il un problème
on vient vous voir
bon quand c'est pas vous c'est moi si tu
dire quand même bien souvent et c'est
trop souvent le cas dans les compétences
lettre les départements font un travail
extraordinaire sur l'aide sociale à
l'enfance quand il ya un gros coup de
grisou ont dit c'est l'état comme si on
avait oublié qu'on avait décentralisé la
compétence je viens on a décentralisé
imparfaitement certaines compétences de
mobilité au développement économique
dès qu'un problème on dit c'est l'état
quand une entreprise sommes jamais vu
une région dire c'est ma responsabilité
je vais moi le faire l'état nous aide
pas on me parle de l'emploi l'emploi si
ça va avec la responsabilité c'est
simple ça veut dire maintenant dans les
élections régionales
quand les gens votent pour la région ils
disent je vote pour la politique
d'emploi
et quand le président les parlementaires
irons aux élections
attention mes chers amis l'emploi c'est
pas chez moi c'est la région moi je ne
peux rien emploi on n'est pas ce pays là
je vous rassure et l'allemagne grands
pays décentralisateur n'a pas non plus
décentralisée où est donc le problème
qu'on a c'est qu'on a décentralisé des
compétences sont décentralisées les
responsabilités et je le dis aussi pour
protéger les collectivités ici présentes
personne en france ne veut avoir un rsa
par département personne ça n'est pas
comme ça que la nation s'est bâti et
donc on va pas dire la politique sociale
niveau complètement les et centralisées
au niveau du département
donc les gens veulent prendre des
compétences et pas les responsabilités
on peut pas avancer comme ça
donc oui un grand débat une grande
avancée sur la décentralisation mais à
condition de dire la compétence va avec
la responsabilité démocratique est clair
et avec des financements clair qu'ils
ont la même dynamique est là nous serons
et une fois que j'ai dit ça j'y suis
ouvert sur tous les sujets on parlait de
logements d'ici très ouvert pour parler
de culture y en a déjà beaucoup
on peut faire là aussi plus de sport d'
j'y suis favorable
suivant ces règles qui sont celles de la
classe et de la responsabilité partagée
vous l'aurez compris mesdames messieurs
chers amis je n'ai d'autre obsession que
d'agir de transformer de fer avec vous
car à la fin il n'ya costa qui compte et
c'est cela que nous laisserons une
action alors je sais les mois à venir
auront un tour un peu particulier avec
les élections municipales qui se profile
certains d'entre vous se représenteront
et je sais qu'ils seraient nombreux avec
aussi de nouveau engagé actifs ou
retraités jeunes ou moins jeunes femmes
deux hommes qui feront le choix de
donner un peu de leur vie aux autres
certains d'entre vous se revendiqueront
d'étiquette partisane d'autres non je
crois sur ce sujet qu'il faut laisser
une totale liberté n'en fermer les
maires dans aucun clivage les élections
locales ne sont pas là pour être utilisé
à des fins partisanes
vous avez besoin de rassembler et d'agir
ce qui compte c'est l'engagement
ce qui compte c'est que la république
des mères vivent ce qui compte c'est que
les maires de france unissent encore et
encore la société façonne encore et
encore le pays continue à forger ce que
nous sommes ce peuple enraciné ses
paysages ses différences et répondent à
ses ambitions contemporaine
car oui comme je l'aï dit notre pays
traverse et je conclurai sur ce point
une période peut-être unique quand on se
retournera sur elle ou ses fractures que
j'ai évoquées sont là où en même temps
les opportunités sont à portée de main
ou quelque chose se réinvente à tout à
la fois de nos vies de nos territoires
de notre continent comme du reste du
monde et
je crois dans ce moment une fois encore
que votre rôle est en effet essentiel
alors oui vous l'avez dit président il
ya un an lorsque le pays s'embrase et
j'ai fait appel à vous ou plus
exactement je vous ai regardé vous
m'avez inspiré j'ai regardé les premiers
maires les premiers d'entre vous qui ont
parce qu'il y avait certains de nos
concitoyens qui étaient dans les rues ou
les ronds points
parce que la violence était là qui ont
ouvert leurs mairies qui ont proposé
certains sont venus me voir avec des
propositions concrètes et de poissy à
gargilesse dampierre en passant par
toutes les communes de france
vous avez pris des risques vous avez
proposé et innover j'ai en ce moment une
pensée remerciement particulier pour
vanik berberian qui avait que ces mères
est venu me présenter ses premiers
cahiers qu'il avait ouvert en mairie
il a aujourd'hui des combats plus intime
mais il a eu beaucoup de courage
beaucoup de courage mais j'ai une pensée
pour vous tous et toutes qui vous êtes
engagés en vous confrontant deux salles
polyvalentes en mairie de préaux d'école
en salle de classe
parfois la colère pour lui redonner un
cadre vous avez écouté
vous avez souvent expliqué vous avez
aussi relayée je vous ai retrouvé à
chaque fois avec des propositions des
voix portée et une ambition alors on
conclure mon propos je voulais vous
remercier d'avoir fait vivre cette
république si vivante si diverse mais
deux bouts forte d'avoir donner un cadre
aux colères et aux indignations et
d'avoir montré une fois encore que notre
république est forte et notre république
continuera dans les mois qui viennent à
affronter ses peurs mais je sais ce que
nous avons vécu ensemble et ce que nous
avons fait ensemble
et ça me rend formidablement trop
optimiste la république
ça n'est pas une nostalgie la république
ce n'est pas non plus un immobilisme la
république c'est une volonté
c'est un projet unique de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité
ce sont des droits on les rappelle
chaque jour où ce combat pour les
étendre
mais aussi des devoirs devoir pour les
responsables que nous sommes partout
devoir pour nos concitoyens il faut leur
rappeler toujours s'il n'y a plus de
devoirs il n'y a pas de droit qui
tiennent devoir de respecter l'autre
devoir de respecter la quiétude et
l'ordre public parce que c'est la
garantie de la liberté de conscience
d'expression comme de manifestations
devoir de civilité car la démocratie
interdite la haine précisément parce
qu'elle est libre devoir d'aimer cette
collectivité qui nous unit qui pressait
précisément eiffel qui prodigue des
droits et sans laquelle rien ne tient
et de la commune à la nation telle est
notre rôle rappeler les droits et les
devoirs à chacun ne jamais face ayez et
ne jamais oublier cette en même temps
républicains auxquels je crois
profondément
oui la république c'est cette soif
d'agir ce sont ces mille fils tendus
cette amitié profonde que nous devons
rappeler à nos concitoyens c'est cela ce
que durant tous ces mois vous avez
montré c'est cela je vous parle très
franchement que nous aurons encore à
faire jusqu'aux élections prochaines
et au delà car nous ne réglerons pas en
un jour ce défi ils continueront d'être
deux ans nous et nous aurons à porter
mais c'est ce qui nous unit
oui quelles que soient les sensibilités
les diversités
alors je suis formidablement optimiste
en vous retrouvant ce soir et on vous
sachant au travail dans les prochains
jours avec le gouvernement je vous ai vu
à l'oeuvre
je vous ai vu faire et avancer et je
sais qu'avec vous la république
c'est une volonté de chaque jour nous
l'avons et nous l'ont alors vive le
maire de france vive la république et
vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]